bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous en direct ce matin sur
rtl france premier grand meeting de
campagne air pour jean luc mélenchon
eric zemmour deux visions de la france
deux candidats de haut vol en tout cas
dans le verbe regardez
nous voulons montrer au pays pour lui
redonner du courage alors qu'il est
plongé dans l'obscurité de débats
absurdes où l'on voudrait qu'il ce
compte là l'autre pour des affaires de
religion ou de couleur de peau nous
voulons dire est programmée une grande
fois de plus dont la france n'est pas
l'extrême droite
la france c'est la sécurité sociale fait
la santé publique c'est l'émancipation
c'est l'école c'est l'art sert ce qu'est
le partage
quinze mille français qui ont bravé le
politiquement correct les menaces de
l'extrême-gauche et la haine des médias
quinze mille français qui ne baisse pas
les yeux et qui sont déterminés à
changer le cours de l'histoire
[Applaudissements]
ne faisons pas de fausse modestie
l'enjeu est immense si je gagne cette
élection ce ne sera pas une alternance
de plus mais le début de la reconquête
du plus beau pays du monde
là on a vu un candidat rodé à l'exercice
d'un côté une première pour l'autre
quelle est votre appréciation de la
prestation d'eric zemmour on sait que on
sait que jean luc mélenchon a beaucoup
de talent au rayon lecoq qu'en avez-vous
pensé sur la forme
moi je voudrais d'abord dire une chose
parce que je pense pas qu'on puisse
commenter ce qui s'est passé hier sans
revenir et 100g 100 m en lumière les
violences qui s'y sont déroulés je crois
que c'est pas
oui mais mais je crois qu'il faut pas le
prendre
seront toutes de la gravité de la
situation et de la gravité de ce qui est
en train de se passer il ya des gens qui
aiment y compris vos confrères
ont été ont été attaqués violente est
menacée il ya d une femme qui a été
tabassé par des membres de l'extrême
droite et il faut rappeler à toutes
celles et ceux qui nous écoutent et à
toutes celles et ceux qui participent au
débat présidentiel que aujourd'hui
l'extrême droite est un danger et
violente alors pour par les moyens que
j'ai examu rossi a été violente et non
il a apparemment une blessure au poignet
oui mais moi je les deux nous nous
l'avons toujours dit à la france
insoumise on est pour qu'il puisse y
avoir un débat pacifique non violent et
pour que les choses se règlent par les
bulletins de vote c'est bien pourquoi
nous avec jean luc mélenchon hier nous
tenions en même temps qu'ils récusent
mbow un discours un meeting pour
l'affronter justement sur le fond parce
que monsieur zemmour si on vient à si on
en vient au fond finalement il n'est
rien d'autre que emmanuel macron en
étant plus ou plus racistes sur les
questions d'immigration eric zemmour il
dit la même chose que il dit la même
chose que la droite a toujours dit et
que les libéraux continuent à dire par
exemple pour redonner de l'argent aux
français il faut pose une baisse des
cotisations sociales
concrètement ça vaut pas pour les
salaires décents ils ne proposent pas un
13e ace qu'il faut pas d'une
augmentation du salaire il a proposé un
troisième mois pour les bas salaires bon
on va en parler d'où vient l'argent d'où
vient l'argent dans là attendez attendez
c'est maxence
il faudrait donner quelques cours
d'économie à monsieur le col juste pour
que vous vous rendez compte que leur
tombe st charge du salaire augmente
c'est mathématique on m'a pas dit si tu
me dis que
c'est compliqué donc les personnes
parlent en même temps c'est vrai c'est
pas comme sur un plateau maxence briquet
je vous redonne la parole c'est promis
en rien le cac
sur la question des salaires je trouve
ça assez incroyable de voir que monsieur
coque en fait exactement la même vision
qui amène macron c'est à dire que l'idée
n'est absolument pas de baisser les
charges pour que les salaires augmentent
vote c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne on
est un pays qui taxent énormément les
gens et nous on envie de redonner
l'argent de leur travail en fait on
n'accepte pas que l'état se gave comme
ça en parfois allons jusqu'à racketter
les gens avec des taux d'imposition qui
sont absolument délirant donc nous on
considère que baisser les charges c'est
le moyen pour faire augmenter les
salaires mais il s'agit absolument pas
de faire ce que vous voulez faire vous
c'est à dire augmenter de manière
presque magique les salaires que ceux
avec de la dette que ce soit avec des
primes sur distribué avec l'argent des
français je le précise qu'une
redistribution absurde qui aujourd'hui
en train de mettre notre système social
abat sur la question des violences mois
encore une fois je le répète la seule
violence qui m'intéresse aujourd'hui
c'est celle qu'elle subir exelmans il ya
un homme qui lui ai sauté dessus quand
même qui est arrivé qu'il a pris à la
tête qui l'a agressée il se retrouve
dans une situation où il a neuf jours
d'itt et eric zemmour donc en fait la
violence on sait très bien de quel côté
elle et j'ajouterais je terminerai par
là mais jean-luc mélenchon avait été
filmée il n'y a pas très longtemps chat
places d'hôtel de ville en train de
menacer un journaliste de morts en tout
cas en demandant à un de ses gardes du
corps de casser la gueule je cite un
retrait qui met un journaliste qui était
en train de l'interroger il avait aussi
menacé des policiers pour une
perquisition donc la violence on sait où
elle est du côté de l'extrême gauche et
certainement pas du côté d'eric zemmour
alors répondez aurélien le coq c'est
vrai que le c'est un point qu'on a entre
eric zemmour et et jean luc mélenchon
il ya eu des attaques verbales en tout
cas de la part d'eric zemmour hier
contre les journalistes et on sait que
jean luc mélenchon n'aime pas
particulièrement en tout cas les
journalistes non plus
je crois va qui hier à la sortie du
meeting de jean luc mélenchon ni aucun
de vos confrères n'est dû être
raccompagnés vers la sortie protégé par
une équipe de sécurité pour pouvoir
sortir sans se faire taper dessus comme
ça a été le cas de vos confrères de
quotidiens et je crois pas non plus que
à la suite du meeting on ait pu
retrouver une jeune fille le visage
ensanglanté à l'extérieur et des
personnes étant à peine capable de tenir
debout parce qu'on les avait frappés au
milieu du meeting avec les chaises même
du mythe et donc je crois que il ya elle
est de ce fait une différence
relativement importante entre eric
zemmour et jean luc mélenchon et
j'aurais attire l'attention sur le fait
que l'extrême droite aujourd'hui amène
un climat en france particulièrement
dangereux qui serait temps que tout le
monde s'en rende compte à commencer par
les journalistes elle aussi une part de
responsabilité
mais je voudrais juste finir te répondre
sur le fond parce que on a parlé on a
parlé justement du salaire mais les
cotisations sociales
c'est une part du salaire ça s'appelle
du salaire différé ce que vous faites en
baissant les charges comme vous dites
les cotisations sociales c'est que vous
baissez le salaire global parce que oui
monsieur lance t aujourd'hui vous allez
à l'hôpital et que vous ne payez pas
pincer une partie de votre salaire que
vous utilisez que vous touchez lorsque
vous pouvez vous soignez lorsque vos
médicaments vous sont remboursés c'est
une partie de votre salaire que vous
touchez pas ce que ce sens parce que ce
sont des droits et c'est la proposition
aujourd'hui que féérique ces mots vous
allez toucher un petit peu plus à la fin
du mois par contre vous finirez par
payer à l'hôpital vous finirez par payer
pour évidemment et lorsque vous serez
malade vous ne pourrez pas être soigné
voilà la france
c'est parce que c'est parce que nous
proposons avec jean luc mélenchon si
monsieur vous savez comment fonctionne
l'économie et le budget de la sécurité
sociale mais c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne je
peux vous faire un tableau assez
rapidement mais vous n'avez pas dû
écouter le meeting d'eric zemmour cela
dit je peux comprendre parce que le
meeting jean luc mélenchon est également
due à mourir 1 c'est à dire qu'on est
quand même sur les mêmes rengaines sur
l'antiracisme nature extrême droite etc
moi j'ai regardé des vidéos je me suis
rendormi deux fois devant monsieur le
coq si vous voulez la prochaine fois je
vous offre des places le meeting the
priest ministre et mieux ça vous ennuie
et sur la question des salaires devrait
faire mal et
répondez moi
monsieur le coq inquiétez pas nous
sommes attachés au pluralisme politique
contrairement à vous sur la question des
salaires nous notre projet c'est de
baisser les cotisations sociales
l'action d'eads accord et l'idée
derrière cette non pas du tout parce
qu'on veut conserver notre modèle social
mais pour les français on veut le
réserver aux français s'appelle de la
préférence nationale c'est quelque chose
qu'on trouve complètement légitime donc
en soi les français n'auront aucun souci
ils vont pas avoir de baisse de leur
modèle social de leur couverture sociale
parce que ce sont les étrangers qui eux
aujourd'hui bénéficie d'une grande
partie des cotisations et de la
redistribution sociale en france qui
vont en pâtir je termine juste sur ça
monsieur coque et après je vous réponds
je laisserais répondre aujourd'hui eric
zemmour il a quand même tenu un meeting
avec 15000 personnes un métier où il y
avait une ferveur absolument incroyable
et où je pense qu'il a vraiment incarner
la fonction présidentielle on le voit à
travers des propositions qu'il a faites
on répète encore une fois les charges
sociales les impôts de production sortir
du commandement intégré de l'otan va
mettre au centre de notre modèle
éducatif les mathématiques les humanités
il a aussi montré une forte capacité à
rassembler la droite il en a appelé à la
faute des cieux de marine le pen à ceux
qui avaient voté pour son ami eric
ciotti à la primaire de la droite on a
vu jean frédéric poisson d'abus moment
conservateur des gens qui sont là les
poids lourds pour appuyer sa candidature
et enfin on voit quelqu'un qui a une
vision pour la france qui veut pas voir
notre pays mourir et c'est aujourd'hui
on va parler du fond aurélien lecoq jean
luc mélenchon lui aussi défend son idée
de la france une autre france
d'ailleurs ils en appellent au
rassemblement lui aussi pas à droite
évidemment mais à gauche mais à la base
la base de la gauche ils n'ont pas on le
sait
le haut du panier puisqu'il ne veut pas
d'alliance avec anne hidalgo ou yannick
jadot a expliqué nous sommes ce
revirement de la part de jean luc
mélenchon
au ces par virement vous savez nous a
fait un moment qu'on avait appelé déjà
il ya deux ans à former une fédération
populaire avec toutes celles et ceux qui
le souhaiteraient aujourd'hui on a lancé
depuis sept étés l'union populaire ce
que nous disons c'est que au delà même
de la droite et de la gauche cette
élection présidentielle elle doit nous
permettre de relever un certain nombre
de défis sociaux démocratique écologique
et qu'elle doit se faire sur la base
d'un programme il ya un moment où les
gens en ont assez des histoires de
tambouille d'étiquettes donc il faut un
programme notre programme il est sorti
en librairie et on le sait puisque
lorsque pour l'attester on voit qu'une
partie de ces propositions les
principales propositions sont
majoritaires dans le pays donc ce que
nous proposons de faire c'est de fédérer
d'unir l'ensemble du peuple français des
citoyens qui sont prêts à soutenir et à
défendre ce programme c'est pour ça
qu'on a créé l'union populaire et hier
nous avons lancé le parlement de l'union
populaire c'est-à-dire des personnalités
des citoyens des militants des
syndicalistes des associatifs qui sont
prêts à porter ce programme a permis
vivre la campagne est donc c'est une
belle dynamique qu'on a lancé hier avec
plus de 200 personnes qui vont animer ce
parlement qui sera présidée par aurélie
trouvé qui à l'ancien porte parole
d'attac donc on a fait comme ça un très
beau meeting avec beaucoup d'énergie
avec avec beaucoup d'envié beaucoup
d'espoir et où je crois jean luc
mélenchon a montré qu'il pouvait être le
candidat est le président d'une france
qui d'une part irait mieux d'une france
où les salaires seraient plus haut d'une
france de la retraite à 60 ans d'une
france de la sécurité sociale d'une
france où les gens ne vivrait plus dans
la fpt dans la pauvreté et puis surtout
d'une france apaisée d'une france où on
ne regarderai pas son voisin en fonction
de sa religion de sa couleur de peau ou
même du papier qu'il a dans la poche
d'une france où lorsque quelqu'un tombe
à côté de nous plutôt que de le frapper
à terre comme font les amis d'eric
zemmour eh bien on le relève et si les
blessés oui on l'emmène à l'hôpital on
le soigne on ne trouve pas de faux
semblant quand même fait maxence briquet
depuis tout à l'heure
deux indiqué sur l'économie complètement
absurde
écoutez déjà la vision de la france
directement on peut dire qu'elle est
radicalement antagonistes à celle de
jean-luc mélenchon ce que je trouve pas
très étonnant dans la mesure où
aujourd'hui on a un petit peu à la
course
au clientélisme permanent c'est à dire
que pour sa copine avec les islamistes
d'un côté puis de l'autre on essaye de
dire encore une fois monsieur monsieur
le coq était là en train de dire que
toutes les propositions que la france
soumise avait fait était vous partagé
par les français alors oui avoir un
salaire plus haut c'est partagé par les
français mais si c'est pour distribuer
des primes avec leur argent à eux et
avec de la dette les français ne sont
pas d'accord c'était complètement biaisé
enfin je l'avais lu l'étude que vous
avez fait et très franchement ça ne
représente rien du tout mais c'est bien
que vous en soyez convaincu la vision
d'eric zemmour c'est la vision d'un pays
qui est en train de mourir d'un pays qui
est en train de mourir d'une immigration
massive d'un déclassement d'entreprises
qui sont surtaxés d'une école qui va
extrêmement mal de d'enfants qui
arrivent en sixième qui ne savent pas
lire d'une décadence sur le plan de la
souveraineté de la souveraineté
énergétique avec le nucléaire qui est en
train d'être mises à bas également par
les amis de monsieur mélenchon donc
c'est un tout c'est un pays qui est en
déclin que les français le perçoivent en
fait hier moi j'ai discuté avec des gens
de gauche qui étaient venus voir eczéma
ou alors pour un style sont pas encore
convaincus ils voté pour lui au premier
tour le nez qui m'ont dit eric zemmour
c'est la valeur refuge pour un second
tour face à emmanuel macron parce qu'il
incarne cette forme d'union des droites
avec d'un côté une droite forte sur le
régalien et une droite qui est aussi
très présente sur le social avec des
près des préoccupations qui sont
vraiment au coeur de la ville est
français on n'est pas en train de plaies
à 10000 à promettre des choses qu'on ne
pourrait jamais tenir comme le fait jean
luc mélenchon on est dans le concret et
c'est aujourd'hui ça qu'on défend alors
et un point commun entre jean luc
mélenchon eric zemmour c'est aussi la
halle la charge contre emmanuel macron
l'ennemi désigné dans cette campagne
présidentielle eric zemmour avions en
2010 est je cite la france a élu le
néant et elle est tombée dedans est ce
que c'est une phrase qui aurait pu être
signés jean luc mélenchon revenir le coq
je crois pas que la france est élu le
néant au contraire elle a élu le
meilleur représentant de l'économie
capitaliste des libéraux des grands
patrons et par ailleurs je suis désolé
de le redire mais eric zemmour ne
diffère pas beaucoup les manuels macron
sur sa politique économique puisque
l'abaissement des charges pour redonner
du pouvoir d'achat c'est la solution
éternel des libéraux je suis sûr qu
emmanuel macron peu en est d'accord là
le départ de la retraite le retard du
départ de l'âge de la retraite à 64 ans
et de fait ce que qu'on fera également
s'il est réélu alors ils passeront
peut-être le meilleur mécanisme mais ils
sont de toute façon exactement dans la
même lignée donc malheureusement je le
dis zemmour c'est la même chose que
macron avec peut-être une matraque un
peu plus ferme mais ça change finalement
pas grand chose et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on a besoin d'avoir
effectivement des vraies propositions et
un vrai changement radical il faut
changer notre système économique c'est
insupportable d'avoir en france 10
millions de pauvres 8 millions de
personnes qui ont besoin de l'aide
alimentaire 7 millions de chômeurs il
faut faire en sorte que les tares et
investissent de l'argent dans l'économie
il faut faire en sorte pour ça par
exemple de passer à la planification
écologique c'est à dire de changer de
modèle de production y compris pour
répondre au défi climatique donc il ya
beaucoup de choses à faire et je crois
que dans cette élection présidentielle
si on vit une période qui est
particulièrement difficile où
effectivement il y a un sentiment de
déclassement est bien plutôt que de se
diviser de se regarder les uns les
autres de laisser passer les discours de
haine eh bien on a plutôt intérêt à
aller de l'avant à construire à mon
nouveau à changer de système économique
à redéfinir la manière dont nous vivons
ensemble avec une sixième république
redéfinissons tous ensemble
souverainement notre démocratie donc il
ya des grandes choses à faire dans le
quinquennat qui va suivre et je pense
que on aurait tort de s'abandonner à
nouveau à la concurrence de tous contre
tous avec que ce soit eric zemmour ou
emmanuel macron parce que finalement
c'est la même chose et maxence briquets
et une réaction comment rassembler et ne
pas diviser c'est ce qu'on reproche
aussi à à eric zemmour la division est
ce que comment est ce que pour vous
aider vous êtes un candidat qui divisent
qui réussira à rassembler en tout cas
moi je suis absolument convaincu qu'ils
aient pour perdre assemblée parce qu'en
fait c'est le sens profond de sa
candidature et à eghezée mourir qu'il
sait pas d'hier matin tient à être
candidat à la présidentielle comme ça
parce que je pense que mes idées sont
majoritaires et
divisés eric zemmour il y est allé en se
disant que marine le pen ne pourrais
jamais gagner l'élection présidentielle
et que les républicains sont aujourd'hui
en partie de centristes avec quelques
exceptions comme eric ciotti qui
aujourd'hui est le seul à défendre une
droite forte nous ne pourra pas gagné
non plus mais ça c'est vous qui le dites
pour l'instant on attend de voir moi
j'attends de constater dans l'opinion
dans les sondages ce qui va ressortir de
ce mythique s'il va ressortir de la
candidature d'eric zemmour qui ont été
au demeurant extrêmement bien
d'accueillir la vidéo de candidature
d'eric zemmour approche les 4 millions
de vues le meeting hier il y avait
quinze mille personnes sur place y avait
soixante quatorze mille personnes qui
regardaient le live sur la chaîne
youtube d'eric zemmour une plus de 20000
surélève du figaro etc y en avait
plusieurs donc on sent aujourd'hui qu'il
ya une dynamique énorme qui est en train
de se créer à sa candidature on l'a vu
parmi les personnes qui étaient
présentes à son meeting il y avait jean
frédéric poisson il y avait le mouvement
conservateur il y avait jacques une
moureaux qui est une ancienne gilet
jaune donc on sent qu'il ya une vraie
union qui est en train de se créer des à
cette candidature et nous on y croit
vraiment à fond pour 2022 on a vu qu'à
eric ciotti avait d'ailleurs créé son
moment où ça l'est républicain on va
voir comment ça évolue en tout cas jean
luc mélenchon a dit je cite la france ce
n'est pas l'extrême droite il vit ce qui
selon vous rien le coq marine le pen ou
eric zemmour
les deux peuvent se sentir concerné
parce que si marine le pen a pris un peu
de retard moi j'entendais c'était vos
confrères de bfm tv je crois qu'ils
disaient en revenant du meeting avait
une petite ambiance d'un meeting de jean
marie le pen au meeting de témoin donc
bonjour je pense que les deux peuvent se
sentir concerné mais qu'est ce que ça
veut dire que la france ce n'est pas
l'extrême droite ça veut dire que
la france elle ne se définit pas sur
l'identité ethniciste elle ne se définit
elle n'existe pas la france en dehors de
la république et la république ce sont
des valeurs c'est un pacte politique
c'est un pacte qui se fonde sur liberté
égalité fraternité
donc quand on dit la france ce n'est pas
extrême droite ça veut dire la france
oui c'est aussi l'égalité c'est aussi la
fraternité c'est aussi la tolérance et
toutes celles et ceux qui aujourd'hui
sont en accord avec ce pacte politique
est bien sont la france et son français
c'est ça le sens profond et un moment où
il faut se souvenir faut réussir à
redéfinir ce qu'est la france il ne
suffit pas de la proclamer comme ça en
disant vive la france sur la france
d'abord non il faut aussi revenir à
l'essentiel et dire qu'est ce que c'est
que la france est bien la france c'est
la république française c'est la
constitution c'est liberté égalité
fraternité
et c'est ça aussi qu'on propose de re
définir tous ensemble avec une assemblée
constituante et une sixième république
donc je pense que lorsqu'on dit
l'extrême droite ce n'est pas la france
c'est aussi de rappeler ben que la
république elle existe peut-être que
elle ne plaît pas peut-être que le
système républicain il ne plaît pas aux
amis de monsieur zemmour mais que nous
on compte bien défendre alors exe mois
là pourtant répété à maintes reprises il
il réfute ce terme d'extrême droite
qu'il n'est pas d'extrême droite
regardez il avait twitté il ya quelques
jours
afin de rendre plus simple et plus
distrayant de votre vie quotidienne je
vous propose un moyen très efficace de
repérer un imbécile ils m'appellent le
polémiste d'extrême droite alors c'est
une
annonce qui lui colle à la peau maxence
brique est ce qu'il va pouvoir s'en
débarrasser il se
il se dit
républicain de droite mais pas d'extrême
droite eric zemmour là encore entendu
hier mais personne ne sa fugue du
qualificatif d'extrême droite en fait ce
sont les gauchistes comme monsieur lecoq
qui sont toujours là à taper sur lui
rond en éludant encore une fois le fond
en dix ans une extrême droite la
démocratie est en danger la république
est en danger mais monsieur vous êtes
vraiment les seuls à croire sa fin c'est
un truc assez incroyable les meetings
vous avez personne qui dit à bas la
république examen n'a jamais dit à bas
la république eric zemmour à la fin de
son meeting il dit il dit vive la
république en parlant de la gauche il
dit les islamo gauchiste oui bien sûr
bien sûr mais c'est une gauche de
laquelle à mon avis monsieur lecoq peut
tout à fait se reconnaître aujourd'hui
on à eric zemmour qui n'arrête pas de
dire qu'il n'est pas d'extrême droite en
fait qu'il le prouve à la fin de son
meeting il suffit de voir la phrase
qu'il a dite il a dit vive la république
et surtout vive la france vive la
république parce que c'est notre régime
démocratique un régime auquel on est
attaché mais on est encore plus attaché
à la france parce que la france c'est
une essence la république ça fait 200
ans qu'on vit sous ce régime là la
france ça fait 2000 ans qu'elle existe
selon les historiens ses dépens en place
du début de la france mais non considère
que c'est quelque chose qui est qui est
vraiment séculaire qui s'inscrit dans
une vision qui va au delà d'un régime
démocratique qui s'inscrit dans une
histoire qui s'inscrit dans des paysages
dans un héritage religieux de la
religion chrétienne
un patrimoine qui est inaliénable en
fait qu'on ne pourra jamais aliéné peu
importe l'origine démocratique si jamais
demain malheureusement la france devient
un régime autoritaire tout cela existera
encore nous voulons sauver la république
qui nous voulons la protéger et nous
voulons sauver la france qui est un
ensemble de valeurs et de deux choses
d'un patrimoine immatériel et matériels
dont considère extrêmement important et
qui va au delà d'un régime démocratique
encore une fois il nous reste une minute
chacun je voudrais une réaction
aujourd'hui un conseil de défense
présidée par par emmanuel macron à lundi
est-ce que selon vous est-ce que
l'exécutif cherche à un court circuiter
finalement se vaut deux meetings de ce
week-end qu'en pensez vous aurélien le
col d'accord
mais je crois que pour ce qui est du
court circuitage des meetings je crois
qu'il serait bon que emmanuel macron
descendent en plein dans l'arène et
accepte de débattre politique et de
débattre de 2022 puisque je trouve ça un
petit peu disons
exagéré amusé de la part de notre
président de la république de ne pas se
soumettre à l'exercice du débat jean luc
mélenchon lui a proposé un débat et puis
encore plus de faire campagne sur les
frais du contribuable en tant que
président de la république pour le reste
pour ce qui est du conseil de défense
moi je pense que c'est au parlement
aussi de prendre des décisions sur la
situation sanitaire et qu'il faudrait
arrêter qui emmanuel macron décide tout
seul puisque vraisemblablement depuis le
début de la crise il a plutôt mal décidé
c'est mal entouré a toujours on a
toujours manqué d'anticipation et on se
retrouve dans une nouvelle vague roue de
nouveau on va devoir prendre des
décisions parce qu emmanuel macron n'a
rien préparé n'a rien anticipé
aujourd'hui on n'a nulle part pour aller
se faire vacciner alors qu'eux ils
rendent progressivement la troisième
dose obligatoire qu'il est très
compliqué de se faire tester parce que
les tests sont encore payants pour toute
une partie de la population donc il
serait temps que emmanuel macron en tout
cas quitte à s'occuper de la crise
sanitaire qui n'en fasse quelque chose
d'un peu productifs et qu'ils fassent en
sorte qu'on puisse s'en sortir maxence
week-end - quelques secondes mais à
écouter pour conclure ça nous fera un
point d'accord avec monsieur lecoq à la
fin de ce débat
je suis d'accord avec lui il ya vraiment
un problème dans la gestion de cette
crise sanitaire ce concept de défense
qu'il soit là ou pas pour court
circuiter les meetings politiques et en
tout cas révélateur d'une gestion
extrêmement mauvaises et crise sanitaire
par ce gouvernement là et dont on ne
peut qu'espérer que ça s'arrête et que
la vie politique puisse reprendre son
cours avec une déclaration de
candidature je l'espère des milieux
macro pour qu'on puisse enfin débattre
avec lui parler du fond merci beaucoup à
tous les deux d'être venu en direct ce
matin pour débattre sur rt france